[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rameau lully ou montéclair différents
compositeurs réunis ensemble dans une
même oeuvre un opéra imaginaire créé à
partir de pièces inédites des xviie et
xviiie siècles
on a été chercher les off on avait joué
depuis 30 ans lorsqu'on avait préféré
et puis d'autres choses qu'on avait dans
nos armoires et qu'on ne jouera jamais
donc c'est une occasion unique
d'entendre je pense ce sera probablement
la première fois une dernière fois qu'on
entendra des oeuvres de stuc de bertin
de la douille de colin de blamont sont
des vrais 16 heures on a fait la propre
histoire propre père en com avait fait
louis xiv avec le ballet ou avec la
comédie une création originale qui
reprend les codes d'un opéra
traditionnel trois solistes interprètent
les personnages habituels
une reine et perdu d'un jeune homme lui
même amoureux d'une princesse des rôles
qui aide à créer une continuité entre
les différents auteurs
je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'on est
quand même sur plus de 50 ans de musique
donc on sent que l'écriture change un
peu le lit et ramos est absolument pas
la même chose donc ses dents ça comment
comment réunir sa essai c'est un défi
mais je trouve ça un défi très
intéressant
un défi pour célébrer les 30 ans du
centre de musique baroque de versailles
et du centre spirituel
les 70 artistes se produiront à
bruxelles paris et metz jusqu'au 15
octobre
dernière étape le 18 à l'opéra royal du
château de versailles
[Musique]
non
on
et on